[Aplausos]
voy a presentar pusieron para quedarse
en casa que tiene un poco de experiencia
personal un poco de mi vida de lo que
hago el trabajo en casa lleva de la mano
un poco con el tiempo el tiempo que
tenemos en la vida las cosas limitado el
tiempo limitado lo tenemos para todos
que pensamos que vivimos una ciudad
donde no hay nada para hacer dónde vamos
al cine oa comer y es lo único que
hacemos normalmente vamos a trabajar
todo el día y pasamos horas y horas y
horas de nuestras vidas haciendo cosas
que a veces no nos gustan no sé si han
visto esta película que se llama in time
si no la han visto no importa les cuento
un poco de qué se trata se trata que el
tiempo es lo más importante y con eso
vivimos y si se te acaba el tiempo que
tienes marcado en el brazo mueres y qué
mejor sitio para hablar de la muerte que
aquí como dijo filiberto en el convento
de la buena web de la buena muerte no sé
si todos saben que se van a morir y si
todos están conscientes de que se van a
morir cuando alguien se entera de que
alguien se va a morir se preocupa y le
da tristeza pero no se da cuenta que
todos vamos a morir en algún momento y
todos tenemos un tiempo marcado para
morir todos tenemos un tiempo limitado
para hacer las cosas en la vida y de eso
se trata esta película un poco el tiempo
también puedes comprar tu comida puedes
hacer la vida que quieres hacer segundo
tiempo si tienes menos tiempo eres pobre
en esta película entonces el tiempo al
final te marca un poco tu existencia
hablando del tiempo empecé a pensar
cuando era niño y como manejaba mi
tiempo este era el tiempo cuando yo era
niño a grandes rasgos tenía un tiempo
para el colegio un tiempo que te lo
imponen prácticamente un tiempo que no
puedes cambiar cuando sales del colegio
cuando yo salí del colegio médica a
hacer cosas que me gustaban a comer a
jugar fútbol a jugar básquet a jugar con
mis amigos a ver televisión a jugar
nintendo tenía un tiempo de estudio
también aparte del colegio no tenía que
hacer mis tareas estudiar para los
exámenes que tenía en el colegio además
ahora a veces mezclan estas cuatro horas
de estudio con las siete horas de
colegio y tus hijos o tus sobrinos salen
del colegio como a las cinco de la tarde
entonces mezclaron todo y van de frente
a jugar obviamente
y después teníamos 8 horas para dormir o
tenía 8 horas para dormir
cuando empecé a pensar en esto dije
porque no en verdad aprovecho todo el
tiempo que tengo para jugar esto lo que
me gustaba hacer a mí
felizmente nació en esta generación que
jugar significa sacar una pelota al
jardín y patearla durante cinco seis
siete horas con tus amigos ahora quizás
ya no cambia un poquito y te dedicas más
a jugar en una tableta o en un celular
pero no importa esto lo que me gustaba
más era mi patear una pelota durante
horas y horas y horas pero claro cuando
salía me va a llamar me dice oye no sé
tú tus tareas tiene que estudiar para el
examen de mañana y qué sé yo me acordaba
que tenía un tiempo limitado para jugar
y para hacer las cosas que me gustaba
entonces empecé a pensar que yo era
dueño de mi tiempo y podía acomodarlo
como mejor quería y a la hora de pensar
en esto dije bueno el colegio no lo
puedo cambiar porque este impuesto yo no
podía decirle al director de mi colegio
oye quiero jugar cuatro horas más así
que voy a venir tres horas nada más no
entonces era imposible hacer eso
lo que yo quería incrementar mis horas
de ocio entonces no podía meter el
estudio en el 200 lo único que me
quedaba era las horas de dormir estás
ocio horas de dormir yo pensé que podría
cambiarlo si podría aprovecharlas para
mí todo lo que hice fue esto tenía más 7
horas de colegio 9 horas para jugar o
hacer lo que me dé la gana o al fútbol
obviamente o patear una pelota como le
dije en el jardín y todas esas cuatro
horas de estudio las trasladé a la noche
a la wta donde yo dormía a la hora donde
nadie me fastidiada y donde estaba
tranquilo para hacer mis trabajos o
estudiar estudiamos me ayudó mucho
además porque cuando empecé a hacer esto
me empecé a levantar muy temprano me
empecé a levantar a las 5 de la mañana
para hacer las tareas que no había hecho
en la mañana cuando juega fútbol y
obviamente todos mis amigos dejaban de
jugar o dejaban de hacer cosas porque
tenían que hacer las tareas yo no seguí
haciendo lo que quería hacer y en la
noche aprovechaba para hacer mis tareas
o mis trabajos
entonces me empecé a levantar a las 5 de
la mañana después a las 4 a la mañana y
por último me empecé a levantar las 3 de
la mañana por suerte no me sentía
cansado al día siguiente algo pasaba en
mi organismo que por más que juego
fútbol vaya al colegio a mis tareas a
las de la mañana no me sentía cansado y
tenía la misma energía levantarme a las
3 o 4 la mañana que las que tenía al
levantarme a las 7
como era normal
esto que pasó en el colegio lo trasladé
también luego a la universidad porque
soy arquitecto y estudia arquitectura y
como saben los arquitectos cuando
estudian no duermen y eso lo aproveche
también a mi favor porque claro tenía
muchos trabajos que hacer y tenía muchas
horas al día
obviamente hay algunas cosas negativas
que les voy a contar también dentro de
un momento que no son buenas cuando
tienes tanto tiempo a tu disposición y
luego también lo trasladado ahora a mi
trabajo que también les voy a hablar de
lo que hago actualmente hago varias
cosas y he podido divertido diversificar
mi tiempo a través de muchas tareas que
hago constantemente hace más o menos
cinco o seis años
y esto lo que pasa en las horas de
colegio en las horas de trabajo
actualmente las horas de trabajo de una
persona normal adulta más o menos están
divididas en ocho horas las personas
siempre te dicen siempre hay tiempo para
hacer las cosas que quieres hacer tienes
ocho horas para trabajar ocho horas para
dormir y ocho horas de ocio para hacer
lo que te dé la gana aquí en lima quizás
esas ocho horas de ocio las trasladamos
al tráfico nos pidió cambiar ocio por
tráfico y teníamos trabajo tráfico y
dormir más o menos no tenemos mucho
tiempo como para hacer cosas que
nosotros queremos y que nosotros
queremos disfrutar todo lo que hice fue
trasladar lo mismo que hice en el
colegio y cambiar un poco esto del
sistema horario que tienen las personas
adultas con su trabajo
este sería el ideal tener 4 horas para
dormir qué es lo que más o menos duermo
en promedio tener 10 horas para trabajar
y 10 horas para hacer lo que me dé la
gana pero en realidad es más o menos así
tengo 4 horas para dormir 15 horas
trabajando o más porque en verdad lo que
hago realmente me gusta entonces trabajo
demás y las horas de ocio muchas veces
están mezcladas y quizás esta línea
amarilla debería ser 20 horas y 4 horas
de dormir esto es trabajo bastante en lo
que me gusta felizmente y lo considero
también horas de ocio
felizmente como les dije al dormir estas
cuatro horas yo no me sentía cansado y
esto me parecía raro porque claro hay
gente que conozco como mi esposa por
ejemplo que duerme ocho horas y es como
un zombi en la mañana tiene que dormir
más de ocho horas es lo contrario a mí
entonces muchas personas que necesitan
más de cuatro horas cinco horas seis
horas ocho horas tradicionales para
poder dormir porque al día siguiente se
sienten cansados no tienen la energía
suficiente para seguir trabajando para
seguir haciendo lo que tienen que hacer
y eso es porque el cerebro necesita
regenerar las células guardar la
información que ha tenido en todo el día
descansar poder activarse al día
siguiente y estar descansado algunas
personas cuando investigue esto un
poquito más
y encontré que había un estudio por esta
doctora que es un gene wifi de
california que hizo un estudio
justamente estas personas que podían
dormir muy poco y estar totalmente
descansados al día siguiente y es una
mutación de este gen del gen dec2 este
gen lo que hace justamente es que una
persona particular pueda dormir menos
horas y estar totalmente restablecida al
día siguiente no me hecho ningún estudio
yo no sé si tengo esta mutación del gen
pero creo que la tengo y estoy
totalmente convencido obviamente cuando
salió este estudio mucha gente decía que
tenía lo mismo pero a mucha gente con
insomnio que no podía dormir y está
hecho un zombi no unas orejeras enormes
y que no dormía nada y que creía que
podía hacer muchas cosas pero estaba
totalmente cansada y su cerebro no
rendía lo suficiente
estas personas que tienen este gen
degenerativo entre comillas por ejemplo
thomas edison
tampoco dormía y pensaba igual que yo
que dormir es una pérdida de tiempo
porque no estás haciendo nada entre
comillas no mucha gente lo piensa como
una inversión para mí no para mí es una
pérdida de tiempo entonces él dormía 30
minutos cada 4 horas
winston churchill por ejemplo otro
personaje conocido dormía cinco horas
separadas en 23 horas en la noche y dos
horas en una siesta en la mañana en la
tarde y tiene una cama en el parlamento
para poder dormir la siesta ahí
la tercera es leonardo da vinci leonardo
da vinci también tenía una un ciclo de
siesta es un ciclo de dormir muy
particular que se llama ciclo de
huberman y este ciclo lo que hace y es
el más extremo por así decirlo que en
algún momento lo voy a probar el dormir
a 20 minutos cada cuatro horas y lo que
él decía que eran siestas reparadoras
para poder trabajar las siguientes
cuatro horas es más o menos en promedio
de dormida dos horas al día lo que le
permitía hacer tantas cosas porque las
hizo obviamente en todo su trabajo a
través de todo el tiempo que trabajó
luego está a margaret thatcher también
que es muy conocida porque dormir
solamente cuatro horas y por último test
la que también dormía solamente dos
horas al día a los 25 años tuvo un
colapso cerebral justamente por dormir
tampoco ya pasaron 25 así que espero que
no me dé ningún colapso y obviamente
todas estas condiciones de no dormir o
dormir poco y trabajar mucho en lo que
te apasiona te puede generar muchos
problemas o cosas negativas no todo el
día tengo mi mamá con retirándome
diciéndote dársenas no vas a poder
trabajarlas ir a la clínica no vas a
poder seguir haciendo lo que estás
haciendo y luego no tranquila porque
estoy descansado creo que tengo una
mutación del gen dec2 así que no te
preocupes entonces estas son las cosas
negativas que suelen pasar a veces
te sientes muy cansado y no puedes lo
que quieres hacer demencia quizás en
algún momento me volver demente no lo sé
o quizás ya suavemente y tampoco lo sé
no dormir dicen que incrementa la
posibilidad de tener diabetes o
problemas cardíacos y que te puede dar
un paro al corazón en una edad temprana
espero también que no me dé un corazón a
una edad temprana y otra cosa importante
es que el contenido es ilimitado hay
mucha información que se genera a través
de películas música series de televisión
charlas como ésta conciertos y en verdad
el tiempo que tenemos es tan limitado
que no nos va a alcanzar para consumir
toda esta información y en verdad me
frustra mucho porque lo que trato de
hacer cuando no debemos consumir mucha
información entonces bueno hay
demasiadas cosas para ver y no me va
alcanzar el tiempo para verlas
hay que saberlo y usted esto lo tiene
que saber espero que nos haya entender
algo por mí como que se van a morir
también que les he contado también hace
un ratito y el el pensamiento de que me
sobra tiempo el pensar que te sobra
tiempo es algo negativo porque dejó todo
para el final
yo no bueno tengo como cuatro horas más
a partir de las once de la noche voy a
poder hacer esto
pero verdad me gane el tiempo y a veces
no tengo tiempo para terminar las cosas
que tengo que hacer así que está este
pensamiento esta recurrencia de pensar
que tengo mucho más tiempo para hacer
las cosas a veces mejor en contra y no
termino haciendo las cosas que tengo que
hacer
entre las cosas que hago comúnmente en
mi trabajo soy arquitecto no me dedico
100% a la arquitectura yo tengo un
trabajo actual que me quita más o menos
el 90% del tiempo que se va a contar
pero también trabajo una arquitectura
con una empresa india entonces hago
proyectos para india con lo cual el
cambio horario que son diez horas y
media de diferencia no me hace mucho el
problema porque puedo trabajar con ellos
mientras los demás duermen entonces para
ellos es ideal que alguien en el otro
lado el mundo pueda trabajar con ellos
mientras ellos están despiertos y yo
estoy aquí trabajando con ellos entonces
tengo un par de proyectos que estoy
desarrollando con una empresa india
también soy piloto de carros corro
carros de carrera en tacna entonces cada
dos meses me voy a tacna a correr un
campeonato automovilismo campeón el año
pasado así que chévere me va bien este
no es que es un hobby y al final pero es
el deporte que me gusta hacer también y
viajo cada dos meses para hacerlo soy
profesor en la universidad en la upc y
en la usil en la disip
en la upc es enseño en la facultad de
diseño y tengo un curso que se llama
producto y comunicación que es
justamente para que los alumnos
desarrollen su creatividad y también
tengo un grupo de diseñadores que se
llama periodista en collective que lo
que hacemos es justamente juntar a
diseñadores peruanos para llevar los
trabajos al extranjero y poder exponer
que el diseño contemporáneo peruano es
de muy buena calidad esto lo hacemos dos
veces al año esta es la primera
exposición que tuvimos en milán el 2017
y seguimos con el trabajo constante para
recopilar diseñadores peruanos para
llevar este talento al extranjero y por
último mi trabajo o el trabajo que me
ocupa el 90% del tiempo es esta empresa
que se llama join us que nada irónico es
una plataforma donde ustedes puede
encontrar todo lo que pueden hacer en la
ciudad todas las actividades que ustedes
creen que se están perdiendo la ciudad
las puedes encontrar acá
puedes encontrar conciertos charlas
conferencias como ésta por ejemplo todos
los que han venido espero todo lo que
han venido hayan comprar su entrada y en
verdad les puedo mostrar todas las cosas
que creen que se están perdiendo porque
no tienen tiempo en ésta
entonces desde el 2003 hasta el 2018 ha
podido diversificar mi tiempo el tiempo
libre que tenía el tiempo que excelente
que tenía para hacer muchas otras cosas
que no necesariamente son mi trabajo y
que no necesariamente sean dormir
en esta investigación que hice es una
investigación que también me demoré años
haciéndola me tomo más o menos 10
minutos es un cálculo matemático bien
rápido las personas que duren duermen
ocho horas al día en un año
duermen dos mil 920 horas esto equivale
a 121 puntos 6 días al año entonces
ustedes están despiertos realmente en el
año solamente 8 meses de los 12 meses
del año
ustedes duermen 4 por si acaso y yo que
duermo 4 horas
y ahí viene
en verdad duermo solamente 1.460 horas
que son 60 punto 8 días
esto equivale a 2 meses al año y quiere
decir que estoy despierto consumiendo
cosas y viviendo más ustedes 10 meses al
año ok esto si lo redondeo más o menos
en una expectativa de vida que en perú
son 75 años yo soy un poco más buena
gente y nos hemos dado 80 años a todos
hemos puesto qué expectativa a 0 80 años
si todos tuviéramos 80 años van a dormir
27 años de su vida
por si acaso es un dato bien fuerte que
me afectó cuando hice el cálculo porque
dije de los 80 años voy a dormir 27 años
27 años durmiendo sin hacer nada estando
cerrando los ojos una cama es horrible y
creo que el concepto que tenía de niño
que estaba perdiendo el tiempo cuando
dormía era totalmente cierto yo al
dormir cuatro horas al día lo que va a
pasar es que voy a vivir 66 años 153 y
voy a dormir solamente 14 y este es el
dato más alarmante para ustedes no para
mí obviamente en mi vida yo voy a tener
13 años más de vida que ustedes voy a
haber vivido 13 años más voy a haber
compartido con mi familia con mis amigos
13 años más voy a poder haber visto 3500
series en netflix más que ustedes voy a
poder leer 28 mil 400 libros más que
ustedes voy a poder ver 775 mil 900
películas más que ustedes en el cine o
en mi casa voy a poder escuchar más de
1.700.000 canciones que ustedes por
último voy a ver más de 500 455 mil
quinientas charlas ted que ustedes
como está obviamente entonces como esta
charla yo voy a poder ver 455.000 y
quizás ustedes vean solamente una
esta charla no es solamente para sacar
la explica de todas las cosas que voy a
poder hacer sino para que se den cuenta
que ustedes pueden manejar su tiempo de
la mejor manera y empezar a manejarlo ya
disponer lo de la forma que ustedes
deseen y haciendo las cosas que ustedes
les gusta dejen de hacer las cosas que
no les gusta plantense un horario en su
casa se duerman ocho horas nueve horas
diez horas o cinco horas plantees un
horario ya que con esas horas a la que
los hagan feliz muchas gracias
[Aplausos]